today on the matt welsh show democrats
are out in force fully trying to
undermine confidence in a coronavirus
vaccine even before it's been released
they're already trying to undermine
confidence and these are the people who
constantly preach about
trusting science and trusting the
experts also five headlines including
joe biden retreating to his basement
once again as the hunter biden scandal
continues to explode
and a rapper releases a hot new joint as
the kids would say i think
confessing to unemployment fraud he now
faces 22 years in prison
for unemployment fraud and in our daily
cancellation i will cancel
phone calls all phone calls are canceled
and i'll explain why
all that on the way but we begin with a
trip down memory lane
you know there was a time you may
remember many many moons ago when
we embarked on a 15-day quest to slow
the spread
15 days to slow the spread that was the
slogan those were our marching orders
except they weren't really
marching orders because we weren't
marching we were sitting in our homes
hiding under our beds but they said
the main thing is just to stay home
social distance oh and whatever you do
don't wear a mask you idiots and then 15
days passed and the orders changed never
mind they said
we'll have to stay locked down until
easter then easter came and went and
they said never mind let's keep this
going for another month
we're having fun why not then another
month passed and they said never mind
actually
we meant two months oh and by the way i
know we yelled at you earlier not to
wear a mask
but now we've decided that you have to
and if you don't you're a murderer and
not welcome in polite society
and then three months came in one and
still the country was under various
different
restrictions and mask mandates we
started hearing that in fact
we might have to wait until a vaccine
arrives before we can
fully get back to our lives and carry on
like normal human beings again in a
functioning society
some of the most optimistic and maybe
naive among us
may have thought that okay well until
there's a vaccine that has to be the
last
goalpost shift the last wait never mind
it's got to be the last surely once
there's a vaccine at least after however
however many
after however many months or years of
being forced to live
like every stranger we meet is
radioactive
surely once there's a vaccine that'll be
over surely
but no no you silly fools there is
infinite space in which to maneuver
these goalposts
they can be moved and shifted
indefinitely for all eternity
which which brings us to the latest
change that now even with a vaccine
we may still have to be under
restrictions because we can't trust the
vaccine
and this we can't trust the vaccine
stuff is not just coming from the once
maligned anti-vaxx crowd
but from the very people who were doing
the maligning of the anti-vax crowd
case in point governor andrew cuomo of
new york now governor cuomo
who consigned many thousands of elderly
in his state to death by sending
infected patients into nursing homes and
who then
even while the pandemic is still
happening decided to write a book
bragging about his stellar leadership
throughout it
that same governor cuomo who could make
a claim for himself i think as the most
evil and certainly
shameless politician in america was on
abc last night
and had this to say about vaccines
listen
how confident are you in the approval
process of the fda right now
well first uh how confident am i
uh i'm not that confident but my opinion
doesn't matter i don't believe the
american people
are that confident you're going to say
to the american people now
here's a vaccine it was new it was done
quickly
but trust this federal administration
and their health administration that
it's safe
uh and uh we're not 100 sure of the
consequences
i think it's going to be a very
skeptical american public about taking
the vaccine and they should be
so what's it going to take to convince
you that it's safe that it's effective
that it should be distributed
well what i said i'm going to do in new
york is we're going to put together our
own group of doctors and medical experts
to review
the vaccine and the efficacy in the
protocol
and if they say it's safe then i'll go
to the people of new york and i
will say it safe with that credibility
but i believe all across the country
you're going to need someone other than
this fda and this cdc
saying it's safe this of course is in
keeping with what many democrats have
said uh though
cuomo is a bit more direct in his
politicization of of
vaccines than other dems like biden have
been and remember again there was a time
when when when
everything you just heard in that clip
would have been dismissed by people like
cuomo as anti-vaxx conspiracy mongering
and that time was all time until 12
seconds ago
and what is he even claiming here that
the scientists behind the theoretical
coronavirus vaccine would put something
out there something dangerous or
ineffective
just to satisfy trump now i'm openly
skeptical of the reliability of some of
the so-called experts but
even i wouldn't make that claim after
all merely from a self-interest
standpoint
they would want the vaccine to be safe
because putting out a bad vaccine on
purpose would at a minimum ruin your
career if not land you in jail so
this attack on the so-called experts
from cuomo goes
much much further than anything you hear
from
other people like trump and this is the
same guy cuomo who who's told us
lectured us ad nauseam to believe the
science trust the scientists trust
trust the experts and so on and so on in
fact in this same interview a few
moments later
he outright says that we cannot trust
the experts at the fda and the cdc
listen the cdc george and
uh the fda doesn't have any credibility
you have dr fauci now
saying that they basically tried to
muzzle him he has the highest
credibility in the nation
on this issue and then
not only is the vaccine safe this
administration is learning
nothing from the past what they're
saying is the day we get the vaccine
that's when it ends that's not true
the day we get the vaccine we then have
to prove to the american
people it's safe we then have to
administer
millions of doses and that is a
massive undertaking that this
administration hasn't even
talked about and is going to take months
and if it's not
done right will be a debacle like
back in january and february when we
made so many mistakes with this covet
virus
no credibility really no credibility
now i'm not going to sit here and say
that the cdc does have credibility on
this
i'm not here defending the credibility
of the cdc that's not my point cuomo is
the one
who's been preaching about trusting the
experts and now he says the cdc has
no credibility well if so why did we
lock down at all why are we still under
restrictions why are we listening to
them on masks
do they have credibility or not cuomo
the answer for him is that they have
credibility
when it's politically convenient for
them to have credibility
just like the vaccine will be effective
and safe if and when
it is politically convenient for it to
be so like if it's released under a
president biden
look there there are perfectly valid
questions you could raise about a
potential vaccine that's rushed through
and
given to the public usually these things
take years a vaccine that hypothetically
has developed in mere months
could raise legitimate questions and if
that's all that cuomo and his ilk
were saying that would be one thing but
that's not their point for them it's all
about donald trump
and joe biden has said that explicitly i
trust vaccines
i trust scientists but i don't
trust donald trump at this moment the
american
people can't either i trust vaccines but
i don't trust donald trump well
what does donald trump have to do with
anything trump isn't the one working on
the vaccine he isn't the one doing the
tests
he doesn't have anything to do with it
why say i trust the vaccines but i don't
trust donald trump well
because he's trying to leave himself an
opening for disputing the efficacy and
safety of a vaccine
should one come out during trump's time
in office which remember
could could be another four years what
if trump wins reelection and a vaccine
comes out in say
may or something will democrats
discourage people from taking it for
four years just to avoid
giving credit to trump you would like to
say that such a thing would be
unthinkable
but it's not unthinkable as they have
shown time and again for the democrats
there is no low that is too low there is
no depth
to which they will not sink all for the
sake of power
and control that's what we're facing
which is something to keep in mind when
you cast your vote
on election day let's get to our five
[Music]
headlines
well nobody wants to spend unnecessary
amounts of time doing uh anything
especially not you know something like
going to an auto body store it's not
exactly a barrel of last not
not not a huge amount of fun so if
there's an easier way why not take
advantage of it there is an easier way
i'm here to tell you rockauto.com is so
much easier than walking into a store
going through that whole rigmarole
you have access to rockauto.com at your
desk in your pocket
uh anytime you just pull out your phone
go to rockauto.com and you're gonna find
always the lowest prices possible and
they're not going to change their prices
based on you know trying to to get
everything they can out of you
rockauto.com is a family business
they've been doing this
for 20 years online serving auto parts
customers and you can go to rockauto.com
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers
they've got the best selection uh that
you're gonna find you're not gonna find
a better selection at auto parts or in
fact what you're gonna find is uh
probably you're not gonna find what
you're looking for they're gonna have to
order it online
anyway you're gonna pay more just go
right to rockauto.com prices
rockauto.com are always reliably low and
they're the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers
everyone gets the same great price the
rockauto.com catalog is unique
easy to navigate quickly see all the
parts available for your car truck
and uh it's simply that's that that easy
so go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
truck right walsh in there how did you
hear about us box so that they know
that we sent you all right um
so cbs news correspondent ed o'keefe
reports that joe biden has called a lid
on the whole week until thursday night
not the next debate
uh we're not gonna see him again
apparently until the debate o'keefe says
joe biden uh still has not answered
any questions about the new york post's
multiple reports about biden's son
hunter and the laptop
not just one multiple laptops apparently
this guy's got
it's got to be difficult to lose one
laptop but this guy has lost
laptops all across the globe he's just
he's been globe trotting
and like johnny appleseed or something
just just dispersing laptops apparently
um and uh and but we haven't really
heard anything from
from uh from biden officially on this
denying it if it was if these uh
now we've heard from some people on the
left and people in the media trying to
run cover for them
and some other elected democrats saying
this is all a russian
this is a this is a russian
misinformation campaign well if that was
the case if they were
if these were just fabricated made-up
emails
uh fabricated at a whole cloth this is
nothing but but fantasy and fiction
then biden will come out right away and
say this is completely made up this is
crazy
and if there was reason to think that it
was a the russians were involved then
biden would say that too
but he hasn't he hasn't said anything
and
and and he has been asked now in
fairness to me he hasn't been asked that
much so it's not like he's
he's had his feet to the fire but he has
been asked a couple times in fact he
stopped for a milkshake over the weekend
and the first question he was asked is
uh what flavor milkshake he got
because this is the kind of media we
have but after that
he was asked about the emails and here's
how that one
chalkers but i wanted to get a what we
call black and white
just wave it away wave the question away
i don't have time to talk about
this ask me something important like
what i'm gonna have for lunch after the
uh or
or you know what am i gonna have for
breakfast tomorrow we'll talk about that
what am i gonna put in my omelet
tomorrow why don't you ask me that what
are you asking me about this for
so it's that easy if you're a democrat
it's that easy but now this means that
biden
will have to whatever excuse he's going
to come up with for this
he's going to have to give it for the
first time
live at the debate now true the
moderator is not going to press him on
it but trump
will talk about it so biden will have to
say something he's not going to be able
to get through the whole debate not even
acknowledging this
he's going to have to give some kind of
answer
and whatever the excuse is he's going to
be debuting that excuse
that talking point live on national tv
with an aggressive opponent standing
right next to him
this seems to me like an incredibly
foolish political strategy now
you know who am i to give advice
especially to a democrat but
it seems to me if these emails are real
which there's no reason to think they
aren't
bet if i'm in the biting camp what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna come out like
right now
and say yes they're real uh you know
come up with every whatever excuse you
want
hunter biden comes out gives a tearful
apology uh and and
you you come up with it doesn't matter
just some bs you could come up with
whatever bs excuse you want especially
because you know the media is going to
be on your side
and then but the point is you just you
get it all out there now
and then you got two weeks before the
election and you hope that people forget
about it by then which they probably
will because
as i always talk about people forget
about everything that would be the smart
strategy
but they're not going with that instead
they're they're dragging this out and
they're going to have joe biden
address it directly at the debate for
the first time
um all right well
another reason to tune in should be fun
to watch number two um
and i say this by the way i say this as
someone who
i think the emails are of course
important and relevant and they
potentially expose corruption
so they they matter they actually do
matter
but i i'm skeptical about how much
they'll matter in the minds of the
average
voter and i'm also i'm i'm a little bit
worried and i
could be wrong i always take the
pessimistic approach as you know so
um i'm not looking for the silver lining
i'm looking for the dark cloud
in you know that's that the silver
lining is encompassing
so from the dark cloud approach uh i i
i do worry whether with two weeks left
in the
campaign is this the best closing
argument
should this be the final argument
against biden should it be something
focused around hunter biden
his his loser scumbag son
even though it involves joe biden too
uh allegedly is it is it best for this
to be the closing argument or
what we have been hearing from the trump
campaign which is that joe biden is a
trojan horse for the far left we talk
about the riots we talk about all this
kind of stuff anti-police everything
else
now yeah you could do both but sort of
one thing or the other has to be your
primary focus especially with only two
weeks left
i tend to still think that the most
important thing the thing is to be most
persuasive
persuasive to voters and that's the
easiest to understand
is the fact that he's a trojan horse for
the far left which is also true
by the way and important so
i'm not really sure number two um there
was another protest over the weekend of
course this one i think in boston
and here's a protester anti-trump
protester apparently pretending to eat
a heart a bleeding heart
just watch
don't worry it's no time
going back for great again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay so this is either mental illness or
drug abuse
or demonic possession or perhaps a
combination of all three
maybe we don't have to choose we joke
about trump derangement syndrome and how
trump has
literally driven the left insane but the
truth is that these people were already
insane they were driven insane
uh many of them from their own sense of
entitlement and their own narcissism
that's what's driven them insane
but what that means is they simply
cannot psychologically handle being in a
position
where things are not going exactly as
they like and want
and that's where donald trump comes in
because they hate him so much
and they were so sure that he shouldn't
be president and then he became
president
and they they couldn't handle it that's
why the classic
the classic clip of the the woman on her
knees screaming no at the sky
what is that it's just she she cannot
deal with
this and this is what we're seeing from
the left
so entitled so narcissistic they cycle
they have a psychological break
when something happens that they really
really don't want to happen
number three democratic senator chris
coons on cnn on sunday is the
latest to come out and explicitly
threaten to add seats to the court
the supreme court speaking of having a
psychological break because things are
happening that you don't want
um if he doesn't get his way in the
barrett confirmation fight this is this
is the threat that he's making listen
if barrett is confirmed and democrats
win back the senate
would you vote to expand the number of
justices on the supreme court if it came
up for a vote is that something you'd be
in favor of
well jake like joe biden i'm not a fan
of expanding the court but
we have a few weeks here to see whether
there are four republicans
who will step back from this precipice
it is president trump
who has pressed for this nominee so he
can have a key vote
to overturn the affordable care act in
the middle of a pandemic
it is the republican majority that's
responsible for racing forward
uh with this extreme unqualified nominee
unqualified because of her extreme
judicial
philosophy and that's who should be
bearing the brunt at the ballot box
in this election that they're doing this
to get someone on the court
just in time a week after the election
to take away critical health care
protections
from a majority of americans we need to
focus on that so you opposed
if we happen to be in the fact pattern
where we have a president biden
we'll have to look at what the right
steps are to rebalance our federal
judiciary
so your mind is open about adding
justices to the supreme court yes or no
just
your mind is open yes your mind's open
okay you know
i think one of the most shocking things
about 2020 probably the most shocking
thing of everything
is that this confirmation fight
has has and maybe i'm speaking too soon
because the final vote is until
thursday i guess but uh so we still have
a few days for this to change but as of
right now
this confirmation fight has been really
easy and smooth we we were all
particularly
predicting a knock-down drag-out
fight-to-the-death kind of situation and
it hasn't been that
yeah they've gone after amy cody barrett
but just with the standard stuff
handmaid's tale comparisons that sort of
thing so just really standard leftist
talking points nothing too you know
nothing too serious
and that's been it um a big part of that
is because amy coney barrett is that
bulletproof
um of a of a of a nominee
but also it makes me again going with
the pessimistic angle uh it
it makes you a little suspicious and
then you realize well
why is it going so smooth because i
think the democrats they're being coy
about it but they
they fully intend to go with the uh
to to pack the court i think they fully
intend to do that now
and that's why they're cutting their
losses here and they're saying well we
can't stop it anyway
uh there's no sense in coming off like
psychotic lunatics any more than we
already do just
in our day-to-day lives so we're just
going to let this kind of happen
because we know what we're going to do
when we're in power
all right number four many reports in
the media claiming that
the owner of the redskins well the the
then redskins
told the cheerleading coach
that he has to keep the cheerleaders
skinny and with big breasts only he
didn't say breasts
uh but but dan signer the owner said
that
that uh they have to be skinny and you
know and and that way
or or the cheerleader coach will be
killed
now i think we can assume the or i'll
kill you
part of it was not meant to be taken
literally
and assuming that the rest isn't much of
a controversy right
of course you want the professional
cheerleaders to be skinny and uh busty i
mean as opposed to what
but the the interesting thing is that
the media headlines are about this
alleged comment from daniel snyder
uh about him body shaming or whatever
but it comes as part of a larger report
that among other things the redskins
allegedly produced lewd videos of the
cheerleaders and the videos were created
and disseminated to someone without the
cheerleaders knowledge
now apparently the other claim is that
the women may have signed a contract
giving the team
permission to make whatever kind of
video they wanted so they might not have
a legal
leg to stand on in any kind of lawsuit
um
but even so it's it's interesting to me
that
that that's the story and you would
think that would be the headlines
instead of the media is making making
headlines about
um about mean comments from daniel
snyder
the mean words are the headline not the
potential alleged softcore porn video
made
allegedly without the permission of the
women involved so you see where
priorities the media go
okay number five finally um i've just
been i've been biting time waiting for
this this is my favorite this is my
favorite story of the year perhaps
a rapper who goes by the name nuke
bizzle
recently released a song called edd
where he bragged about
getting rich off of fraudulent
unemployment claims
and he has now been arrested for filing
fraudulent unemployment claims
he's accused specifically of access
device fraud aggravated identity theft
and interstate transportation of stolen
property
faces up to 22 years in prison um after
being apparently mailed
92 debit cards loaded with collectively
over a million dollars in benefits that
he then turned around and
used uh i think at least half of it
uh so he he he did all this now now this
is
you can you can almost see where he's
coming from a little bit because
rappers routinely brag in their music
about committing crimes so i think nuke
bizzle figured well
i mean they brag about it so why can't i
but the problem is that he bragged very
specifically about a particular crime
that's easily proven see if you're gonna
do this as a rapper and brag about
committing crimes you have to be you
have to be a lot more vague than that
like you can say that you've killed a
bunch of people but if there's a
specific
open investigation into a murder and you
confess to it
by name in a rap song
and even film yourself dancing around
with a murder weapon probably you're
going to go to jail
and that was the mistake kind of subtle
but that was the mistake that nuke
bizzle made
anyway i know you're hoping and praying
right now that i'll play the song for
you and uh your prayers will be answered
without further ado here is the great
artist nuke bizzle
with his masterpiece and he like he
he paid dearly for this song so i think
we should all enjoy it and appreciate
his sacrifice uh but here's his
masterpiece edd
listen created your card now has been
activated
and is ready for use
[Music]
eddie go to the bank of the stack at
least these
are better than cmps there's some wreck
that i couldn't believe
10 cards i got a shot at the donald
trump
i just might swipe me alone so i'm in do
you're having money
i
[Music]
[Music]
the cpap
[Music]
[Music]
now i think the main guy you just heard
there uh full disclosure was not nuke
bizzle
the youtube video says it's nuke bizzle
featuring fat whizza
a rapper named fat wizard now i don't
want to engage in stereotypes or body
shaming myself but
i'm assuming that the first gentleman
rapping in the video
was fat wizard given that he's well
fat but in any case notice the lyrics
what what what 12 or 13
of them i could actually understand he
says you got to sell cocaine i can just
file a claim
i'm doing the stuff that you can't i'm
smart and you ain't
yes smart well that's one word for it
fat wizard
wouldn't be the word i'd choose but
things are open for interpretation i
suppose
i do want to say though credit where
it's due there was one part of this
video
um that that i saw it and i thought it
was legitimately
positive so here i will look at the
silver lining
uh and i think there's one part of the
song that had a great message and i
wanted to show that to you also watch
this
you got the name and number and i got
the edit we can put something together
i got the alien cat ain't even show me
here
baby hit on my feet head mirror in my
jeans
[Music]
okay so he's talking about killing
people is of course he's of course
bragging about felony fraud fine fine
fine but
in the video he's actually um you can't
see this if you're listening to the
audio podcast but it's
it's it's not reflected in the lyrics
but in the video he's wrapping
uh in one scene with a toothbrush he's
got his toothbrush in the bathroom
and he's kind of like brushing his teeth
he's also rapping at the same time just
like i do every morning in fact when i'm
brushing my teeth
and i think that's a really positive
message about oral hygiene
that's the main headline for me as a
hopeless
optimist i see that and i think okay
that's what this is really about these
guys defrauded unemployment
in order to be able to fund and shoot
this psa for oral hygiene
and maybe this will start a trend and
all the rappers will try to one-up each
other
by showing off their elaborate dental
care routines it's possible
next thing you know like drake is gonna
have a video where he's guzzling
listerine out of a
golden chalice i mean who knows it could
be a positive development
that and that's what i'm going to take
from this i in this case i will i will
see the positive
so uh best of luck to nuke bizzle
um and i would hate to think that he
goes to jail for 22 years
and we are deprived of
his music it'd be hard for me to even go
on in a situation like that
all right before we get to our daily
cancellation um
you know we've been talking about the
the coveted lockdowns and everything
obviously small businesses have taken
the brunt
of a lot of these draconian and
i think suicidal measures that the
government has put in place
um and that's why it's so important
to you know to understand how to
navigate
and lead your way through a crisis
that's why we're excited to tell you
that this wednesday the daily wire guide
king himself jeremy boring
is going to be presenting alongside a
team of world-renowned business leaders
at
expert ownership live it's a two-day
virtual conference about leading through
crisis the conference features a lineup
of speakers
like leadership author john maxwell the
founders of duck commander and otterbox
um the benham brothers many others who
can relate to what entrepreneurs and
leaders are going through right now
they'll share stories about their own
businesses and startup journeys
the tough times that that come with with
running a company and also they're going
to tell you about how to
make it through and be stronger on the
other side of it so visit
expertownershiplive.com
walsh to register for 197 and get a
second ticket for a friend for 50
off you don't want to miss jeremy you
don't want to miss this whole experience
expert ownership
live dot com slash walls to reserve your
spot this wednesday
for 197 and an opportunity to get a
second ticket for 50
off again expert ownership live dot com
slash
walsh all right time for our daily
cancellation today we're going to cancel
phone calls nobody's allowed to talk on
the phone anymore for any reason
i have to put an end to it it's gotten
out of hand there is simply no good
excuse to engage
in this kind of primitive barbarism
anymore it amazes me still every day
that in the year 2020 there are still
people
lots even even probably billions of
people who will intentionally pick up
their phone
dial a number and attempt to have a
purposeful live conversation
with another human being on the other
end this is flabbergasting to me
my gast is officially flabbered by it
and i'll tell you why
first of all in 99 out of 100 cases
whatever's being communicated on the
phone could have been communicated with
greater efficiency
through another method like text message
or email
or depending on the situation simply
waiting until you see the person face to
face
my wife is notorious for this she'll
sometimes call me while she's out and
i'm at home
17 minutes into the conversation i'll
say wait a second where are you right
now
and she'll say oh i'm in the driveway
pulled in 16 minutes ago
but there are worse offenders than this
consider the sort of person this is the
worst kind of person
period in existence the sort of person
who you you text a question to them
could be even a yes or no question
literally a question that would require
a one-word response
and they call you to deliver it or the
sort of person and this is
often the same sort of the exact same
person who will text you and ask to
schedule a time
to talk on the phone and if you're me
you know you'll try to schedule the chat
for some time in the year 2027
but invariably you end up chatting
sooner than that and what always happens
the things that the thing they wanted to
talk about they could have simply
said to you through the initial text
message there was like
one additional sentence of information
they wanted to communicate
and for some reason they insisted on
doing it through audible dialogue
why is this a problem well because
everyone knows
phone conversations come with baggage
there are strings attached there are the
initial pleasantries
leading up to the meat of the discussion
and then branching off down a million
unrelated avenues
and finally the length finally the the
lengthy goodbye process which usually
involves me saying
something like all right gotta jump off
or the classic
uh i'm gonna let you go now translation
i don't wanna talk to you anymore and
hope to never speak to you again
ever in my life you blabbering bore but
whenever i drop one of those hints
the other person always just charges
through
continues paddling on and i have to
continue strategy i have to continue
strategizing new ways to end the
conversation
it's a game of chess basically a
showdown that's how i view every
phone conversation you should know if
you've ever spoken to me on the phone
i could tell you right now i spent the
entire conversation
strategizing ways in my head to end it
everything i said in the phone
conversation was really my attempt to
segue into a conclusion
that's it now i might feel differently
if phone conversations in real life
function like they do in the movies
perhaps you've noticed and this has
bothered me for years because it's so
unrealistic
that people in movies when they're
talking on the phone they never say
goodbye
one person or the other simply reaches
what they believe to be the end of the
exchange and they hang up
unannounced oftentimes too there's no
hello
there's no hello there's no goodbye no
small talk
every phone conversation in movies goes
like this
person one calls person two person two
picks up the phone but doesn't even say
hello
person one not flummoxed by this then
delivers a piece of information like
meet me tonight at 11 o'clock under the
bridge
and person two then just hangs up never
says a word not one word
and person one isn't offended there's
never a scene where person one
follows up with a text message and is
like dude why'd you hang up on me
i didn't even tell you what bridge yet
there are 14 bridges in this town where
how do you know where we're going to
meet
what's going on are you okay that never
happens
the phone conversation is as efficient
as a text message but with a touch of
esp
where the two sides already know certain
things about each other's intentions
without it being said out loud now if
that's how it was in real life
maybe i'd be okay with people calling me
but it's not so i'm not
what i hate most about phone
conversations aside from how frivolous
and unnecessary and boring and
circuitous they always are
the other thing i hate is that i'm
speaking to a disembodied voice
that is injecting itself directly into
my eardrum it's a
it's very unnatural and intrusive i
can't read the voice's body language it
can't read mine
and there can't be any gaps in the
conversation that's the worst part
actually
when you're talking to someone in your
living room it's okay for there to be
gaps and pauses and breaks you can run
into the kitchen you can go to the
bathroom
where neither person is saying anything
but in a phone conversation
gaps are torturously awkward they can't
be tolerated and so the empty space
in the conversation must always be
filled which only leads to more banal
small talk
which extends the conversation that by
any measure should have petered out long
ago
and the absolute worst of all the person
calling you
simply by the act of calling you is
intruding into your day with no concern
for what else you might be doing
when that phone rings it's like someone
running into the room going
let's talk now we have to talk now now
now now now now talk now talked out
and then when you do talk thinking it
must be an emergency
they say they say something like oh hey
just checking in
it's unacceptable by simply calling
someone in the first place you are being
at a minimum rude
but probably i would argue that making a
phone call is itself an immoral act
worthy of eternal damnation that's why
phone calls are canceled
there will be no exceptions i don't want
to hear any guff about how
well i'm out of town on business for
three weeks and i want to talk to my
kids
don't give me the sob story rules are
rules
phone calls are canceled and we will all
be better off for it
that's it today thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening
godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
we'll tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there you